magnus have you do you have thoughts on
the big dress code
controversy nakamura was jeans was
wearing jeans the other day feeder
wasn't happy with it he wasn't happy
with fiji
not being happy do you follow that
no
i don't follow that
should i
i don't know
what's your take on dress codes in
general
um
generally i'm usually fine with
wearing wearing a suit uh
as long as you know
or at least you know a jacket as long as
the if
uh the venue is properly ventilated then
that should be should be fine
um
i mean i'm finding it hard to
to care too much
uh
you guys have any serious opinions
well i remember i remember when event
was kasparov who really much uh pushed
it i think that the player should be
wearing a suit
not tied though but
suit back in the late 90s i think that
was kind of a turning point in elite
tournaments that they started to
establish this kind of role
in the
in the pca events rapid events that we
have to show up very properly dressed
and
but of course many things are so
different from all days right i mean i
remember when i was a teenager we didn't
have press conferences after the games
people just uh
i remember anand and kramnik made a very
quick draw in this vienna variation and
then they just left and
the media and the
press was complaining but at least if
they make a draw we want to have a few
words why did they do
i mean nowadays there are so many things
different right well of course magnus is
very young
so i'm not sure you remember those those
days when we didn't have press
conferences after the game
thank you for calling me young that's
the first time
in a bit
um yeah i
i shouldn't
so i have to call you definitely young
yeah for sure uh no but what i would say
though is that uh the tie a bit uh i
always have that in my contracts that i
don't have at work
don't have to wear a tie because
i i feel
suffocated when i have to well i have to
wear those um